[Music]
join our weekly Amazon giftcard giveaway
all you have to do is be subscribed to
our channel like this video and leave a
comment about today's topic we will
choose winners randomly from the
comments section hey guys as soon as the
official trailer has been released many
fans started speculating that it pretty
much confirmed Jamie's death as he is
most likely charging on drug on vile on
the other hand many fans also started
speculating that Jamie will not die but
will rather become the dragon player in
this video I will try to provide you the
most accurate answer on those
speculations about Jaime Lannister's
deaths and about him becoming the Dragon
Slayer let me first let's say that this
battle will take place upon Randall
Turtles betrayal over Tyrells that will
eventually resulted him leading his
forces along the Jaime leading the
Lannisters forces from Highgarden Jaime
and Randall will manage to conquer Seeta
House Tyrell but they will get ambushed
by the Nemesis forces on their way back
home if you would like to hear more
details about this Randall's huge
betrayal over house Tyrell and about
Jameson Randall's conquest of Highgarden
as well as about the nares ambush on
them feel free to check out my previous
videos in which I provided you all
details however I do agree with most of
you and I believe that Jaime is charging
on dragon in this particular shot now
you're most likely wondering will Jaime
managed to kill dragon anvil Jaime
become the Dragon Slayer well throughout
the history of Westeros they're written
down a few cases in which bolts and
arrows have successfully brought down at
least a few dragons including a
legendary dragon by the name of Marek
says that was written by Rey nice
Targaryen during the war of conquest
meraxes was mentioned throughout the
series by Arya Stark in the second
season
violet Harrenhal Tywin Lannister
recounted to Arya the history of the
castle timing was talking about how it
was designed to defend against an attack
from the land but could not stand a
chance against Aegon and his dragons on
me Charlie replied with it wasn't just
Aegon riding his dragon it was Rhaenys
and Visenya too Rhaenys rode meraxes
Visenya rode vhagar
however this dragon that was said to be
capable of swallowing an entire horse so
skilled I adorn You sheriff in the first
Dornish war it is possible to kill
dragons but so Jaime really
managed to kill Jorgen it most only
would be his greatest deed and would
fulfill his empty pages in the famous
book of brothers the book of brothers is
the term that records the deeds of every
knight who has ever served in the 300
year history of the Kingsguard it was
shown three times throughout the series
and each time it gave us a huge hint or
foreshadow the Jaime so far half empty
pages will be fulfilled until the end of
series this famous book was shown in the
season 4 premiere for the very first
time when Joffrey read through some
entries particularly those of Sir Arthur
Dayne answer Duncan the tall when
Joffrey came to Jaime's rather brief
entry Joffrey sarcastically remarked
that someone forgot to write down all of
Jaime's great deeds zombie Jaime replied
with there is still time three episodes
later in the fourth episode of the
fourth season the book of brothers was
shown once again and yet again
foreshadow Jaime's upcoming deed that he
will be remembered for in that episode
Brienne read aloud Jaime's entry during
their goodbye conversation which is
basically a few sentences mostly
regarding his betrayal of her king whom
he was supposed to protected his own
life as soon as brilliant finished
reading those few sentences Jaime said
that it is a duty of the Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard to fill those pages
and highlighted that there is still room
left on heads later in the same season
there's one more scene in Jaime's
reading this book it's safe to say that
all seems that included Jaime in the
famous book of brothers sir
foreshadowing the upcoming deeds of
Jaime which will be one of the greatest
acts written down in this same book well
there's no doubt that Jaime's great
deeds will fulfill his pages until the
end of series I don't think killing
dragon will be one of them as I said in
very beginning of this video many fans
have also been speculating that this
shot of the nearest mounted non-drug on
preparing to save her famous line drew
carey's
which is a command to burn someone or
something down is representing James
failure to kill dragon and will be burnt
alive but that is definitely not the
case Jaime Lannister will charge on
Daenerys mounted on jørgen but he will
not kill dragon neither will be burnt
alive before Jamie manages to get near
dragon he will be interrupted or more
accurately saved by Bronn whereupon they
will escape and seek the refuge at
Casterly Rock which will be one of the
main reasons that Willy Daenerys attack
and conquer this planet sir stronghold
the nurse'll figure
that conquering Casterly Rock is of the
crucial importance at the Lancers will
not be able to seek the refuge over
there once she decides to attack King's
Landing
in conclusion Jaime will not be burnt
alive neither will become the Dragon
Slayer but I'm sure he will fill his
pages in the book of brothers which in
my opinion he will provide by once again
killing a ruler he was supposed to
protect with his own life in my opinion
Jaime will become a clean slate by
killing his lover and sisters Cersei and
will once again save a hundreds of
thousands of innocent lives if you would
like to know more details about this
theory feel free to check out my video
by the name the gold wedding or the new
red wedding I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next peace
[Music]
[Music]